[Music]
getting there is an arduous trek but
still tourists come in droves from
around the world all to see a rare
natural spectacle a real life erupting
volcano but all that most get to see
from a distance is
just a little smoke lava flows you know
a little smoke and cooling lava
volcanoes are not known for being
cooperative
and the spectators are kept at a
distance for their own safety
the only way to look right into the
crater is to book a spin in a helicopter
this way they can get some really
spectacular views
[Music]
but even with no chance otherwise of a
good look into the crater more and more
tourists are flocking to fagradas viat
a pay parking lot has appeared on the
lava field complete with toilets and hot
dog stands
how can that be
the answer is surprising
all the volcanoes in private land two
different private lands
it may well be the only privately owned
volcano on earth
and that has triggered a public debate
in iceland
can a natural phenomenon serve as a
private moneymaker
the owners have stopped making public
statements about it
and local authorities appear to have no
plans to intervene
i don't think
that is a job of any municipality to be
kind of
earning
money on
something like this
this is their land they have their
rights but nature guide margaret blondel
maintains that the volcano belongs to
all icelanders
just like the geysers and glaciers
she's been to the volcano several times
since eruptions began in march
she sees it as a fascinating place and
worries that it could end up like other
natural wonders elsewhere because you
lived
in a country with
not so many people that you were always
able to access
and
and all of a sudden there were these
buses
full of people around and everyone with
cameras and
and like you're saying
trucks with food
and snacks
and it changes
everything
many changes could soon be in store for
the volcano not from the capital
reykjavik real estate agents are
reported to have already contacted the
landowners
it's quite the attractive location a
soothing volcano conveniently placed
between the capital and the
international airport
but local authorities are playing down
fears of any major changes to the
landscape
maybe having here some service for the
tourists
but uh i don't think that we will be
seeing here
five-story hotel buildings i don't think
so for now iceland's government has laid
down the law stating that access to the
volcano must be granted to all no matter
who owns it
and should the volcanoes activity cease
public interest will likely disappear
too taking their real estate speculators
hopes with it